all right getting ready for cpac  coverage i'm gonna go through three  different events we're gonna see at cpac  and instead of you having to waste an  hour i will tell you in one line what  they are going to say okay the first one  is a panel called i escaped from  communist north korea the talking point  there will be kim jong-un is bad and  democrats  are like kim jong-un and they want to  make the united states like north korea  i just saved you an hour second panel  all the news the left permits that  anti-vax fox news guest alex berenson  will be there and so will papa john the  pizza guy the talking point will be  the right allows you to explore ideas  like anti-vaxx and the left doesn't and  so the left is bad i just saved you  another hour and lastly kimberly  guilfoyle will be giving a speech  there's only one word you need to know  about that one  mania  i just saved you an hour guys